Julius thank you so much for being here
today you're welcome so why don't you
start by telling me about what
experience or Insight LED you to start
founding your company yes yes so I grew
up here in Africa my name is Julius
moele I'm the uh the principal investor
for mobile American Technology city uh
two billion dollar City invest in Kenya
yeah so I grew up here in Africa and
I've always wanted to change your
community I've wanted to develop you
know the continent yeah in a way that
you know will get a stable middle class
Empower you know the people in Africa
and let them own the resources that they
have on this continent of Africa
challenge you faced when trying to do
this exactly so when I began like
building the city this two billion
dollar City the biggest challenge is
land you want to build a city you need
land and so what we did we had to get
the community to be able to partner with
us and then become a a leader and a
manager for this city so now we have an
integrated Community Development plan
where we have the community as part of
the ownership of this city
very cool now I think a lot of the
things I've been hearing from Young
Founders today is that they have this
idea and they they want to make it
happen but you know there's all this
bureaucratic red tape and they don't
know how to get around the governments
and partner with them what advice would
you give to to people who were in the
same position you were in and trying to
do that exactly so when you have an idea
yeah you have to go out and yeah you
know share with other Founders share
with other people test it in the market
you know because you know the most
important thing when you're starting a
business it's getting the capital and to
get the capital for idea you go into the
market and test the idea up yeah get a
proposal from the market and then come
up you know to be able to raise Capital
yeah you know from other founders of
venture or Venture team or Facebook now
speaking of
the the state of the AC Market here and
is it easy to raise capital is there
anything that needs Improvement here
exactly so so the VC Market in Africa
it's very young specifically in other
markets I come from Kenya yeah it's a
young VC Market I'm mostly dominated by
European companies Venture Capital
companies you know coming in of late we
have the U.S companies coming in but the
market is growing so for Kenya for
example you had billions of Shillings
with VC that went out you know last year
and we're expecting those numbers to
grow according to data by over 75
percent in the next three years and so
in a decade we're looking at having a
well-established you know VC Market in
agriculture in Agro processing yeah you
know in Tech you know I.T Healthcare and
energy so those are four regions where
the VC Market is basically kind of you
know dominating and permuting you know
within Africa what would you say are the
biggest misconceptions about
entrepreneurship or Founders in Africa
right now yeah the biggest misconception
is that Africa you know is the only
place in the world you know most people
don't understand it's the only place in
the world where Fortune 500 can be
created within a half a decade yeah you
know companies can be started and
they'll be making a billion dollars
within half a decade 70 of the
population under the age of 30. yeah so
you have the biggest resource in Africa
it's labor and most people don't see
that they think biggest resource is oil
and gold and diamonds in Africa the
biggest resources in labor so yeah
Highly Educated you can come here you
can get you know very affordable over
and they're they're well they're very
Innovative you can you can create your
your product or your business and be
able to move it on a global stage within
five years for a fortune 500. wow yeah
amazing thank you what is exciting you
um in the the entrepreneurship and
Founders space is there anything you're
looking to invest in or any examples of
things that you think are up and coming
and really exciting exactly big one in
Africa today so we have three areas we
have Healthcare very big in Africa
governments and countries are going for
Universal Health Care you have a youth
population here yeah we're talking about
fertility rates you know being high 20
30 years most of this population over 70
of over 70 percent will be over 50 years
old so they're going to need you know
treatment and Healthcare number two is
aggrocessing agriculture Africa is big
on agriculture and so aggro processing
and you know value addition it's a big
market now for an investment for example
there's a company in Kenya that got you
know funding from Wall Street yeah
you're not doing you know aggro
processing and value addition for food
and it's over a billion dollar company
and all that and of course number three
you're in Tech you know in Tech area so
Tech is grown mobile tech specifically
and and the young people on digital
internet penetration is grown in Africa
is way higher Kenya is almost 90 percent
you know internet growth yeah so you can
basically invest into Tech and you're
going to reach all the 1.3 billion
people in Africa very cool now I I know
you're a businessman but I also want to
talk to you about your philanthropic
Endeavors and the the good you're doing
for the content tell me a little bit
more about that exactly so I'm a
chairman of a foundation called the
American Institute for African
involvement so two billion dollars in
assets it works in 54 countries in
Africa about 3 000 staff and volunteers
and we work in uh our governance you
know entrepreneurship governance we work
in healthcare yeah we work into social
economic development yeah and then
making sure that you know we have Africa
you know free from corruption with
gender Equity yeah within the continent
yeah so we're targeting more the biggest
one of the biggest Flagship projects
we're doing is that we are paying for
communities that can't afford health
care to have insurance yeah so we do
that you know all of Africa and now
we've partnered with hospitals we
partner with governments to pay for
communities either for premiums
Healthcare I thought of the people that
are very poor will pay you know payco
pays for and so we're doing that in last
year we paid eighteen thousand yeah
co-pay is not enough for uh 18 000 uh
premiums and copies for families 18 000
families we are able to benefit you know
last year oh my gosh and my
female entrepreneurs and women
entrepreneurs involved in Africa and
what are you doing to to help promote
that exactly so what what we've done
because you know uh digital digital
penetration is an equalizer yeah you
know for both men and women like for
example I've looked into Kenya you have
young people coming up with YouTube
channels and and we're working with you
know female Founders to be able to do
that right our our city has partnered
with female quotient it's an
organization based in Los Angeles the
headquarters is building our city and so
they have four thousand square feet to
do gender Equity so female question does
gender equity in Fortune 500 for women
and so they have selected Kenya in our
city as the headquarters for Africa and
so we are working together to be able to
basically bring gender Equity all over
Africa with Africa first ladies you know
and we started that project last year
and we're gonna continue with it this
year at the at the G20 in India wow well
fantastic Mission thank you so much for
being here I appreciate it